I'm in San Diego on my way to the border
with Mexico during a time of heated
debates about president Trump's proposed
border wall but today I'm joining a
group of musicians from both countries
who are coming together to play a
cross-border concert in a show of major
solidarity
[Music]
the us-mexico border is a heavily
militarized area with permanent
surveillance and enforcement but on this
day there are also drums cymbals and
flutes percussion it's on both sides
brought music out of the concert hall
and into one of the most politically
charged ons in the country the us-based
musicians are students and members of
the San Diego Symphony Orchestra before
the concert
some of them held rehearsals with the
Mexican percussionists on the other side
today though the glaring wall dividing
them was hard to ignore this is a really
unique part of the border right now
called Friendship Circle and every
weekend the US opens that first gate
over there for four hours to allow
people from the US side to come speak to
their loved ones and talk to them on the
Mexico side which you can see right
there people on either side of the
border travel for hours in order to have
this rare opportunity to talk to each
other and to touch each other's hands if
possible the circle is within an area
called Friendship Park which was
established in 1971 by first lady Pat
Nixon as a symbol of friendship between
the US and Mexico Nixon said at the time
that she hoped the fence wouldn't be
there for long it was the idea of
friendship across borders that inspired
conductor Stephen Schick to organize the
concert well sound is this great
unifying factor right and it is for me
the interconnectedness of human beings
is what makes us human and so the fact
that we can't really see through the
border fence but we can hear through the
border fence and we can play with our
friends the fact that we can play and
communicate through sound no matter what
anybody else in some other city in the
world decides is the great message
[Music]
while watching I wondered what the
experience felt like on the other side
musicians from all over Mexico came to
take part in the concert the first ever
of its kind since Thomas muy emocionado
Cybercom a very future follow us on our
esta muy muy padre porque estamos de
compartir musica para el mismo tiempo
estamos DVD dos por por esto no esta
cosa de metal
there are currently barriers along the
us-mexico border that stretch for 653
miles Trump is still pushing for money
to fortify the border and build a 722
mile barrier
he said that any immigration deal must
guarantee funding for the wall and is
asking for 18 billion dollars meanwhile
in a desert outside San Diego US Customs
and Border Protection is testing the
wall prototypes created by private
companies to see how well they can
withstand attempts to climb smash or
tunnel under if Trump gets the money
he's requested the agency will award
contracts for construction to the best
designs any changes to the wall will
likely be felt here at Friendship Park a
place Adriana Hasso comes to regularly
she's part of an immigrant rights
advocacy group that tries to ensure
access for families to meet are you
worried that everything going on with
the Trump administration right now we're
only gonna see a bigger wall and more
fortification along this border it is
concerning this is a political contract
never seen before at the same time I
think that what he witnessed today what
we saw today is also a manifestation of
hope and it's also opening the hearts
and the minds of people who never
thought about it billions of dollars go
into making dispenser reality enforcing
immigration law but also I think today
was a manifestation of those and the
Aegon's that perhaps hadn't thought
about there is offense and the defense
divides families
for some of the musicians like Daniel
Chava Dean today's concert was personal
give a message to the Mexicans on that
side who weren't able to cross over and
see the full performance here I'm
Mexican myself and you know I have
family on the other side as well and I
just wish that they could experience the
other side do you think President Trump
needs some more music in his life I
think so
I think so something to keep him calm
[Music]
hey guys it's Deena and I'm on the
us-mexico border make sure you check out
more of our videos in the direct from
playlist and let me know where you think
I should go report next tell me in the
comments and be sure to like and
subscribe to HD plus